on a un site qui à 240 salariés qui a
embauché 60 personnes pour pour ce
projet et qui a des partenaires ici dans
la région et au delà qui continue à
faire travailler qui sont donc en
quelque sorte même tiré par cet élan
productif donc oui c'est non seulement
bon pour les entreprises qui aujourd'hui
produisez sont impliqués dans ces
programmes de manière directe et les
quatre sites en france qui produiront
donc ses 250 millions de vaccins en 2021
mais c'est bon pour tous leurs
partenaires et tous leurs sous traitants
je le disais quatre sites celui ci est
le premier a commencé mais quatre sites
produiront ses 250 millions de doses en
france en 2021
je ne vais pas révéler de secret
industriel donc je ne vais pas donner le
nombre de doses précises qui est
produite ici et par site
par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ils ont commencé ils sont en
train de monter en puissance très
fortement expliqué que fin avril début
mai on sera à pleine cadence et qu'on va
encore monter durant l'été les cadences
avec vraiment une mobilisation 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
si vous montre que quand je dis que nous
tous notre pays est mobilisé sur le
vaccin
matin midi soir et durant la nuit c'est
dans les centres de vaccination c'est
pour aider soigner administré des doses
mais c'est aussi pour les produire et
donc c'est vraiment un effort de guerre
collectif et national